vous prenez place
ressortant sortie
la parole
et donc au rapport spécial de la
commission des finances monsieur Gérard
Longuet
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
messieurs les ministres pardon mes chers
collègues je suis j'interviens en
qualité de rapporteur de la commission
des finances des crédits de
l'enseignement scolaire et mon message
sera d'une grande sobriété dans les 7
minutes qui me sont impartis à tout
prendre il vaut mieux voter ses crédits
parce que nous avons un diagnostic
partagé et même si le budget n'est pas
en lui-même parfait mais la perfection
est-elle de ce monde elle a le mérite ce
budget à le mérite de poser de répondre
partiellement à des questions pour
lesquelles nous avons le même intérêt et
assez largement un diagnostic commun
quel est le ce premier diagnostic qui
nous serait partagé sur le ministre
c'est que notre enseignement n'est pas
terrible et que dans les et lorsque l'on
disait cela il y a une dizaine d'années
était un débat politique aujourd'hui
nous pouvons nous appuyer sur des études
assez objectives celle de l'OCDE
c'est des études internationales teams
je pense aux études de la DEPP Direction
des études et là prévisions
programmation et nous avons donc un
regard plus objectif sur la qualité du
travail que produit notre enseignement
scolaire
des résultats ne sont pas tragiques ils
ne sont pas à la hauteur des ambitions
d'un grand pays comme le nôtre et
particulièrement dans le domaine des
sciences et des mathématiques
pourquoi j'accepte votre budget parce
qu'il poursuit ce qui a été initié par
votre prédécesseur des évaluations
exhaustives de l'ensemble des élèves aux
primaires et au début du secondaire je
crois d'ailleurs que non seulement vous
poursuivez ces évaluations mais que vous
entendez les élargir
votre prédécesseur avait lancé le
Conseil national des nations des écoles
le démarrage est long il n'est pas
satisfaisant puisqu'à l'origine il
s'agissait d'évaluer une fois tous les 5
ans tous les établissements scolaires du
pays et donc de rappeler au chef
d'établissement qu'ils seront évalués
en réalité le rythme est beaucoup plus
long puisque 5% seulement des
établissements ont été évalués
nous ne sommes pas au niveau de
satisfaction mais le mouvement est lancé
et manifestement l'idée d'un
établissement qui rentre des comptes est
une idée qui chemine et qui progresse
parce que vous poursuivez cet effort
parce que vous acceptez l'idée que
l'enseignement français aussi superbe
soit-il fort de ces traditions et de son
histoire puisse cependant être jugé par
des observateurs extérieurs qui ont le
mérite d'apaiser nos propres conflits et
bien sur ce premier diagnostic je
considère qu'on doit vous suivre
le deuxième
diagnostic sur lequel je serai un petit
peu plus long dans les minutes 7 minutes
tout avance très vite c'est évidemment
le statut des enseignants parce que à
l'origine nous avons constaté que les
maths à la commission des finances que
les maths étaient de moins en moins bien
enseignés en France on s'est donc posé
la question mais est-ce qu'il y a pas un
problème d'enseignant et en fait on a un
problème global d'enseignant
l'enseignant a vu son statut je le dis
avec tristesse plutôt se dévaluer dans
la société française d'aujourd'hui pour
toute une série de raisons sur pour
lesquelles sur lesquels j'ai travaillé
dans le rapport écrit que je ne
préciserait pas je n'approfondirai pas
dans cette intervention orale si ce
n'est peut-être pour constater que les
jeunes diplômés français ne sont plus
candidats au poste d'enseignant
que des domaines des disciplines fortes
comme la c'est les sciences les
mathématiques d'une certaine façon
certaines langues modernes ne sont plus
demandées je crois que vous avez été
amenés à repousser des dates d'examens
de concours parce qu'il n'y avait pas
assez de candidats on a donc le devoir
absolu de se poser la question du statut
de l'enseignant et de ce point de vue là
les comparaisons internationales que
nous avons lancé la commission des
finances sont quand même assez cruels
sur notre conservatisme tranquille
heureux mais décalés des réalités je
veux dire par là que le système salarial
français est l'un de ceux qui en Europe
est à la fois modestes il est en même
temps celui qui constate l'écart le plus
grand entre les salaires des enseignants
et les salaires de jeunes diplômés ayant
les mêmes qualifications après quelques
années d'activité nous avons une
pyramide salariale qui privilégie la
fidélité c'est une valeur à laquelle je
crie totalement mais il faut reconnaître
que la fidélité n'est pas très motivante
pour mener une carrière puisqu'on avance
qu'à l'ancienneté et on atteint les
sommets de l'ancienneté parfois avec
près de 30 ans de carrière ce qui est
évidemment pas très mobilisant donc nous
avons fait dans ce budget monsieur le
ministre un effort alors soyons lucides
cet effort dépend très largement de la
variation de l'indice l'augmentation du
point de la fonction publique tout le
monde en profite y compris d'ailleurs
les parlementaires ici présents et cette
variation n'est qu'une façon de
rattraper l'inflation et sur l'effort
que vous faites si je retire le gvt le
point d'indice nous avons à peu près 60%
de l'effort socle et les mesures
catégorielles pour les enseignants que
vous avez proposé et fait adopter ne
sont ne sont pas suffisamment
hiérarchisés
en fonction des besoins particuliers
aider les jeunes enseignants aider le
primaire aider les enseignants qui sont
face à des publics plus difficiles et
naturellement et je ne sais pas très
bien comment on peut le faire aider les
enseignants dans les disciplines qui ont
du mal à recruter donc nous avons ce
problème du statut de l'enseignement
dans les 36 secondes qui me restent je
voudrais évoquer le troisième diagnostic
qui peut être partagé c'était l'as
l'effondrement de la démographie
française qui se traduit par une
diminution de 50000 dès maintenant dès
cette année les effectifs qui rentrent
dans le primaire et pour 2020 la rentrée
2023 on attend une diminution de près de
60 000 comment gérer cette diminution on
peut diminuer le nombre de professeurs
vous le faites un peu c'est par la seule
réponse on peut améliorer l'encadrement
où on peut faire du qualitatif
c'est-à-dire revaloriser la situation
des enseignants plutôt que faire du
quantitatif qui n'aurait plus de sens
aujourd'hui c'est la raison pour
laquelle vous avez posé ce problème vous
n'avez pas tranché ce budget 23 est un
budget de compromis nous aimerions
connaître votre conviction sur la façon
d'utiliser au mieux les conséquences
pratiques d'une tragédie française son
échec démographique je pense que le
débat nous permettra de parler entre
nous
et en particulier avec la majorité
sénatoriale que je voudrais convaincre
je ne suis pas sûr d'y parvenir mais
avec le débat des amendements je pense
que il y a eu beaucoup de bonnes volonté
de part et d'autre nous sommes dans un
système de cohabitation que personne n'a
voulu si ce n'est les électeurs français
dans un système de pouvoir partager je
crois que nous pouvons essayer de rendre
service à notre éducation en utilisant
chaque opportunité de progresser merci
madame la Présidente
généreuse quand même déjà
ah mais j'étais passionné c'est pour ça
que j'ai laissé dépasser le temps
mais monsieur gros Perrin va nous
indiquer la suite
[Applaudissements]
monsieur croira rapporteur pour ami de
la commission de la culture du gazon de
la communication qui a la parole
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues les crédits
de la mission anciennement scolaire
s'établiront en 2023 à plus 58 milliards
d'euros soit une hausse de 3,5 milliards
les forces financiers réels monsieur le
ministre mais tradit-il vraiment une
vision de volonté un projet que nous
devons porter pour l'enseignement
scolaire en France
ce budget nous incite à la vigilance et
nous attendrons ce soir vos réponses
avec exactitude sur vos intentions sur
un ensemble de choses sur l'avenir de
notre jeunesse de la France car c'est la
France qui est en jeu
la revalorisation des rémunérations des
enseignants si essentiels avec le socle
635 millions et le pacte où nous
attendons aussi des réponses il
suffira-t-elle à enrayer à produire le
choc d'attractivité nécessaire de ce
beau métier mais au combien difficile et
trop souvent et pas assez souvent
protégé cette crise de vocation connaît
aujourd'hui l'éducation nationale ne se
réglera pas que par le financement et le
délai supplémentaire description des
enseignants de 15 jours prouvent en tout
cas que cette annonce de 2000 euros en
début de carrière ne suffit pas car le
mal est plus profond
et votre budget est-ce que nous essayons
de traduire à travers les lignes que
nous lisons nous interpellent
vous oubliez la revalorisation de tous
ces acteurs qui agissent au sein de
l'éducation nationale quid de
l'augmentation des CPE quid de
l'augmentation et du statut de chez
établissements du nouvel réforme quid de
l'augmentation salariale des infirmiers
et des médecins quid de tous ces
enseignants qui ont commencé leur
carrière à moins de 2000 euros et qui
après 10 ans sont légèrement au-dessus
de 2000 euros et qui permet à ce jour
dont s'interroger sur leur déroulements
de carrière le deuxième point de
vigilance c'est le nombre de postes
pourvu après les concours 2022 on
disputera qu'il y a eu un double
concours qui a eu des difficultés je
vais bien l'entendre mais il est triplé
par rapport à 2021 et ça propose en tout
cas ça met une difficulté forte pour
cette grande nation qui a du mal à
recruter ses enseignants avec une
formation sur quatre jours l'heure est à
une réflexion globale et ambitieuse que
nous avons peine à deviner nous devrons
le deviner comme il y a eu t-il de
stagiaires en Rep qui ont démissionné on
s'interroge également sur l'absence de
mobilité géographique qui peut être d'un
autre temps ou d'une RH de l'éducation
nationale qui n'existante pour la
mobilité de suivre son conjoint pacsé ou
dans d'autres situations j'ai peur que
ce soit un moment donné un gâchis je
vous rappelle que favoriser la mobilité
fait partie des objectifs et limites en
tout cas les risques psychosociaux
troisième point de vigilance les 430 000
élèves en situation de handicap près
d'un tiers d'élèves dans le premier
cycle n'a pas d'accompagnement humain
comment une nation aussi grande que la
France peut laisser ses enfants au bord
du chemin enfin en conclusion comme le
temps qui met un parti est restrein
Monsieur le Ministre ce budget n'est pas
tout à fait à la hauteur de nos
espérances et d'une grande nation comme
la France et le fait de mettre ce
marqueur de 2000 euros ne doit pas
masquer les difficultés que les
enseignants sont en tout cas enclins à
exercer leur métier et c'est pourquoi la
Commission des
un avis d'abstention
la parole est maintenant Madame Nathalie
Delattre rapporteur pour avis de la
commission de la culture d'éducation de
la communication
madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres et je vais dépasser juste un
petit temps Madame la Présidente parce
que je peux je ne peux pas ne pas saluer
la présence de Monsieur le Ministre de
l'Agriculture sur les bancs à la demande
de la mission d'information et cela a
été répondu favorablement donc c'est une
reconnaissance de l'enseignement
agricole et je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre d'être raisons ce soir donc
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues c'est une première j'ai
l'honneur au nom de la commission de la
culture de rapporter le budget sur le
programme 143 enseignement agricoles
doté pour 2023 de 1,59 milliards d'euros
soit une augmentation de 67,8 millions
d'euros par rapport à 2022 au-delà de la
hausse attendue des dépenses de
personnel notamment compensation de la
revalorisation du point d'indice
l'augmentation des crédits de la mission
s'illustre surtout au travers d'un bel
effort en faveur de l'école inclusive à
hauteur de 10,28 millions d'euros
supplémentaires pour 2023 puisque le
nombre de jeunes en situation de
handicap accueillie dans l'enseignement
agricole à encore progressé de
6% cette année s'agissant du schéma
d'emploi 15 et TP supplémentaires sont
prévus sur le programme 143 pour
renforcer les équipes médico-sociales je
me félicite de cette hausse des ETP
après une baisse conséquente l'année
dernière mais je serai particulièrement
vigilante alors évolution à court terme
car l'enseignement pédagogique par petit
groupe est à maintenir impérativement je
souhaiterais cependant vous alerter sur
des chiffres de la rentrée 2022 le
nombre d'élèves scolarisés au sein des
établissements d'enseignement technique
agricole est en baisse de 1,1% cette
année soit une diminution de 1743 élèves
la situation des brevets de technicien
supérieur agricoles les BTS et
particulièrement inquiétant puisque les
effectifs dans ces formations qui ont
pourtant fait leurs preuves en temps on
diminué de 12,8% par rapport à la
rentrée précédente il m'apparaît
indispensable de mettre en place au plus
vite un groupe de travail pour
revaloriser le BTSA et lui redonner une
perspective claire dans une dynamique de
Bac + 3
plus encore cette nouvelle baisse des
effectifs souligne avec force la
nécessité d'agir pour mieux faire
connaître l'enseignement agricole après
avoir ouvert une enveloppe de 9,7
millions d'euros au service de la
communication sur le plan de relance
pour 2022 je déplore que les crédits ne
soient pérennisés qu'à hauteur de 1,9
millions d'euros sur le programme 143
pour l'année prochaine si les campagnes
de communication ont bien fonctionné à
leur lancement il y a trois ans force
est de constater qu'elles ont manqué de
visibilité en 2022 il est indispensable
de mieux cerner les attentes des jeunes
et d'encourager les établissements au
niveau local à se saisir à leur échelle
de ces enjeux en ni assantant leurs
élèves d'autant plus que l'enseignement
agricole se distingue encore cette année
par l'excellence de ces résultats c'est
d'insertion professionnelle très élevées
et son caractère innovant reconnu cette
qualité d'enseignement doit être remue
et s'en inspirer monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale enfin je
souhaiterais terminer en interrompre
votre attention sur la nécessité plus
que jamais d'accompagner les
établissements renseignements techniques
agricole face au contexte énergétique
tendu et à la hausse globale des coûts
de production notamment au niveau
alimentaire les établissements
d'enseignement techniques agricole sont
particulièrement énergivores en raison
du fort taux d'élèves en internat 50%
des élèves de l'enseignement technique
agricole sont internes surtout souvent
même le week-end il m'apparaît donc
essentiel de venir au plus vite soutenir
les établissements de l'enseignement
technique agricole public et privés pour
leur permettre d'absorber les retombées
de l'inflation qui mettent gravement en
péril leur trésorerie pour les mois à
venir il existe déjà une solution simple
pour les maisons familiales et rurales
et les établissements privés du temps
plein ne pas demander le remboursement
des subventions de fonctionnement non
consommer cette année et déjà voté au
PLF 2022 néanmoins et en raison d'une
augmentation satisfaisante de budget
consacré à l'enseignement technique
agricole je vous indique que la
commission de la culture de l'éducation
et de la communication à donner suite à
mon rapport un avis favorable à
l'adoption des crédits du programme 143
consacré à l'enseignement agricole je
vous remercie
on les rapporteurs de l'éducation ne
donne pas l'exemple
tout ce cumulé la parole est maintenant
Monsieur Eric gold dans la discussion
générale
madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres monsieur le président de
commission Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues la mission
enseignement scolaire vit cette année
une forme de rupture avec l'ampleur de
l'augmentation de son budget l'école
creusée républicain cristallisant la
convergence des valeurs fondatrices de
notre société l'humanisme
l'universalisme et le progrès se doit de
refléter la maxime la fin justifie les
moyens monsieur le ministre je crois la
sincérité de votre engagement pour la
revalorisation de l'enseignement la
réussite de tous les élèves et une école
innovante et inclusive luttant contre
toutes les inégalités
vous prolongez la dynamique engagée
depuis 2017 avec une augmentation
inédite du budget de la mission de
l'ordre de 6,5% par rapport à 2022
néanmoins je ferai quelques observations
en effet si ce PLF traduit les efforts
significatifs visant à améliorer la
rémunération des enseignants le retard
accumulé était considérable il est donc
essentiel que ce choc d'attractivité se
poursuive le métier d'enseignante
traverse une crise sans précédent les
problèmes liés à la difficulté de
recrutement ne sont pas seulement
d'ordre financier le manque de
considération sociale de soutien
hiérarchique et des conditions
d'exercices dégradées dans certaines
territoires expliquent cette
désaffection des chiffres ont été
rappelés
en 2018 135 000 candidats se présentent
encore au concours de la fonction
publique de l'éducation nationale
aujourd'hui ils ne sont plus de 90000
plus grave encore les postes ont été
couverts qu'à 83% en 2022 par les
candidats ayant été admis le recours
croissant contractuel présente un
intérêt en ce qui permet de combler un
manque et réadapter progressivement les
effectifs aux besoins réels cependant
n'est-il pas antinomique de pallier les
pénuries d'enseignants par des
contractuels aux qualifications plus que
variables qu'en parallèlement la
formation initiale se tourne vers des
compétences professionnelles renforcées
la revalorisation des rémunérations
constituant l'essentiel de la hausse des
crédits de la mission ne doit être que
la première marche d'un objectif plus
large de reconnaissance économique et
sociale du corenseignant
rappelons qu'en 1990 un professeur des
écoles débutant touchait 1,8 fois le
SMIC contre 1,5 fois aujourd'hui en fin
de carrière un agrégé de classe
exceptionnelle touchait alors 4,6 fois
le SMIC contre 3,3 actuellement
notons également que la rémunération
d'un professeur des écoles est
inférieure au salaire moyen des
fonctionnaires civils de catégorie B
la comparaison avec nos confrères
européens est également inquiétante dans
le fossé ses creusé les enseignants
français commencent et terminent leur
carrière avec un salaire inférieur à la
moyenne de l'Union européenne
dans le contexte inflationniste inédit
que nous connaissons cette
revalorisation est souhaitable mais
au-delà de la conjecture elle est bien
évidemment une affaire de statue
mon autre interrogation concerne les
accompagnants des élèves en situation de
handicap le renforcement des crédits
dédiés à la scolarisation des élèves en
situation de handicap explique une
partie de la hausse du programme 230 la
politique d'inclusion scolaire connaît
en effet une hausse de 11,4%
nous faisons face à une augmentation
spectaculaire du nombre d'élèves en
situation de handicap 430 000 élèves
aujourd'hui deux fois plus qu'il y a 10
ans
dans ces conditions la création de 4000
postes à ESH constituent un effort
conséquent cependant compte tenu des
conditions précaires de travail et de
rémunération de nombreux postes ne sont
pas actuellement pourvus en cette année
ce sont ainsi mille emplois qui
n'avaient pas trouvé preneur à la
rentrée 2022
aussi mon groupe sera bienveillant à
l'égard de l'examen très prochain par le
Sénat de la proposition de loi visant à
lutter contre la précarité des aesh de
nos collègues du groupe ser
j'ajouterai à cela un problème de
cohérence entre la politique des maisons
départementales des personnes
handicapées des fameuses MDPH et les
capacités de l'éducation nationale à
accueillir et à gérer financièrement ce
dispositif
espérons que la création de ces postes
supplémentaires ne soit pas qu'un simple
effet d'affichage mais le point de
départ d'une meilleure coopération entre
ceux qui prescrivent et ceux qui
organisent ainsi que là aussi d'une
meilleure considération d'une profession
aujourd'hui indispensable enfin je
souhaiterais revenir sur la volonté
d'anticipation des grandes évolutions
démographiques en cours et qui touchent
le nombre d'élèves scolarisés en France
si le taux d'encadrement s'améliore la
France se caractérise toujours par un
nombre d'enfants par classe nettement
supérieur à la moyenne européenne
particulièrement dans le premier degré
dans le contexte tendu que je rappelais
ou le nombre de postes à pourvoir n'est
pas comblé par le nombre de lauréats au
concours le principe de réussite pour
tous n'est que trop vacillons nous
sommes donc face à un vrai défi remplir
le rang des professeurs ce qui passe de
le répète par la considération de leur
statut mes collègues
du groupe RDSE vautrons néanmoins
favorablement les crédits de cette
mission merci à vous
la parole est un monsieur Max Brisson
pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
organisé avec Françoise Laborde dans
notre rapport sur la revalorisation du
métier d'enseignant une marche va donc
être franchie c'est une bonne chose
c'est la raison pour laquelle notre
rapporteur spécial Gérard Longuet la
commission des finances ont donné à
votre projet de budget un avis favorable
à contrario Jacques Opera notre
rapporteur pour avis et la commission de
la culture et d'éducation ont soutenu et
obtenu une proposition d'abstention et
comme lui je m'étonne face à un milliard
affiché que pas grand chose nous soit
annoncés en termes de réforme de
structure pour renouer avec
l'attractivité du plus beau métier du
monde alors Monsieur le Ministre
dites-nous enfin être précisément
comment attentions
et sensible de ta carrière comment
allez-vous mettre un terme aux bizutage
institutionnel des néoditulaires qui
prennent leur premier poste dans les
zones les plus difficiles sans
accompagnement
comment allez-vous créer des postes à
profils et des contrats de mission pour
que les carrières soient moins linéaires
comment allez-vous enfin prendre en
considération les secondes carrières
comment avec un nombre de comptes
actuels croissants votre budget
prévoit-il pour eux une politique de
formation de suivi d'accompagnement bref
comment cette proportion croissante
engage-t-elle le ministère dans une GRH
spécifique
infinie comment entendez-vous plus
globalement améliorer la gestion rh du
ministère quels moyens allez-vous y
consacrer autant de questions sur
lesquelles nous n'en trouverons ni
ambition ni détermination il en est du
même du plan école du futur vous voulez
donner plus de liberté d'autonomie aux
établissements et à leurs enseignants et
vous avez raison
les établissements les professeurs les
élèves ont besoin de confiance en leurs
initiatives ils ont besoin que
l'administration centrale croit en eux
et rampe avec une culture verticale et
centralisée qui innervent son
organisation malheureusement qu'en
est-il de l'effectivité de vos sages
intentions que je partage pourtant en
quoi le financement piloté par le haut
d'initiative plus ou moins en lien avec
le sujet de l'autonomie engagera-t-il
école vers cette autonomie peut-il y
avoir une autonomie pour les écoles
primaires alors qu'elles n'ont pas de
personnalité morale peut-il y avoir une
autonomie sans directeur d'école
primaire exerçant une réelle autorité
sur les professeurs peut-on encourager à
l'autonomie sans remettre en cause
l'armature rigide du collège unique et
sans élargir l'expérimentation des
sixièmes trompeurs peut-on redresser
notre école sans la recentrer sur
l'essentiel c'est à dire la transmission
des savoirs fondamentaux peut-on
réaffirmer sa mission première sans la
délester de ton de problème de notre
société qu'elle doit prendre en charge
qu'elle ne peut régler et qui réduisent
d'autant le temps qu'elle peut consacrer
à sa première mission lire écrire
compter monsieur le ministre certes vous
additionnez des volontés multiples pour
répondre à des problèmes quand une
résonance dans l'opinion est-ce là une
politique à la hauteur des enjeux sur
les deux sujets pourtant majeurs de
votre budget que sont la revalorisation
des enseignants et le plan école du
futur la seule politique que nous lisons
c'est celle du pilotage à vue masqué par
la rhétorique monsieur le ministre de
calme déclaration des tensions
consensuelles finiront par ne plus
masquer une faiblesse d'action elles ne
font pas dans tous les cas une politique
nationale nous attendons une vision pas
uniquement des crédits en hausse notre
attente est si peu satisfaite que
beaucoup de sénatrices et de sénateurs
du groupe les républicains s'apprête à à
tenir vos propos sont donc très attendus
et nous y serons particulièrement
attentifs et nous ne perdrons pas par
ailleurs de vue l'analyse d'autres
rapports spécial ni notre rapporteur
pour avis je vous remercie merci la
parole est maintenant madame Colette
mélo pour le groupe Les Indépendants
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
le métier d'enseignant est souvent
considéré comme le plus beau métier du
monde
Marcel Pagnol décrivait malicieusement
les professeurs
œuvrant en quatre coins des départements
pour y lutter contre l'ignorance et
glorifier la République une belle
définition toujours d'actualité
pourtant force est de constater que ce
métier semble aujourd'hui être frappé
par un désamour profond et je suis
particulièrement préoccupée par la crise
du recrutement très visible dans
l'enseignement scolaire bien sûr nous
partageons tous cette inquiétude surtout
en ce qui concerne le premier cycle la
baisse du nombre de candidats au
concours est un signal d'alerte clair le
nombre de postes non pourvu à tripler
depuis un an pour atteindre 3756 en 2022
les témoignages de directeur
d'établissements se sont accumulés au
cours des derniers mois pour alerter sur
le manque de personnel aujourd'hui c'est
la question des démissions de personnel
qui remontent le recours au actuelle ne
représente pas une solution
satisfaisante sur un temps long les
conditions de travail les évolutions de
carrière proposées la mobilité
géographique la rémunération sont autant
de sujets majeurs dont nous devons nous
saisir pour y répondre le projet de loi
de finance consacre plus de 1,1 milliard
d'euros à la hausse des rémunérations du
personnel de l'éducation nationale comme
annoncé pendant la campagne
présidentielle 300 millions d'euros sont
destinés aux enseignants qui acceptent
d'effectuer des missions complémentaires
je souhaite souligner cet effort il
s'ajoutent aux avancées promises permise
par le Grenelle de l'éducation d'autre
part environ 60% des enseignants
pourront recevoir la prime d'activité au
cours de l'année 2023 enfin de nouvelles
mesures de revalorisation
salariales ont été annoncées pour les
enseignants débutants à partir de la
rentrée 2023 c'est une excellente
décision qui permettra je l'espère de
favoriser de nouvelles vocations
plus généralement les crédits
enseignement scolaires dans le projet de
loi de finance 2023 s'élève à 58,8
milliards d'euros ce qui représente une
hausse de près de
6,5%, c'est un effort considérable que
je salue les crédits destinés à l'école
inclusive augmente également on parle de
2,4 milliards budgétaires c'est une
bonne chose ce projet de loi de finance
crée 4000 nouveaux postes
d'accompagnement des élèves en situation
de handicap les aesh nous pouvons nous
en réjouir mais ce n'est pas suffisant
les rapporteurs soulignent le fait que
44% des élèves en situation de handicap
ne bénéficient pas d'un accompagnement
dédié cela ne peut plus durer nous
devons rendre ce métier plus attractif
et améliorer les conditions de travail
car les aesh sont les chevilles
ouvrières de l'école inclusive
nous pouvons également nous satisfaire
de l'accueil d'environ 20 000 jeunes
Ukrainiens au sein de nos écoles les
académies de Nice et de Versailles sont
en première ligne les retours sont
positifs et je salue l'implication du
corps enseignant pour permettre à ces
jeunes élèves de se sentir les bienvenus
dans nos écoles leur présence a
également permis de souligner les
lacunes en mathématiques des jeunes
Français les élèves du système scolaire
ukrainien en tenant d’avance semble-t-il
par rapport à nos élèves dans ce domaine
cela confirme les mauvaises places que
la France obtient au sein des
classements internationaux
cette prise de conscience collective
doit se poursuivre dans le temps pour
combler notre retard et je suis heureuse
de la décision du gouvernement puisque
les cours de mathématiques seront
réintégrés aux enseignements
obligatoires au lycée cette décision va
dans le bon sens et doit s'accompagner
de décision forte pour relever le niveau
moyen des élèves enfin je souhaite
saluer votre engagement monsieur le
ministre dans la lutte contre le
harcèlement scolaire et le
cyber-harcèlement rappelons qu'un jeune
surdit ses victimes de harcèlement nous
devons
œuvrer collectivement pour permettre à
tous les établissements de protéger
leurs élèves c'était l'objet de notre
échange lors de votre venue au collège
Louis Braille à Esbly en Seine-et-Marne
où l'espace jeunesse et le collège les
collèges sont lauréats du Prix non
harcèlement en 2022 le clip de
sensibilisation contre le harcèlement
scolaire a été diffusé à partir du jeudi
10 novembre la lutte contre ce phénomène
doit faire partie de nos priorité dans
les années à venir j'y suis
particulièrement attachée car l'école
doit préparer les élèves à vivre dans
une société bienveillante en respectant
autrui pour les différentes raisons que
je viens d'évoquer le groupe Les
Indépendants accueille favorablement les
crédits enseignements scolaires je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole
maintenant et Madame De Marco pour le
groupe écologie solidarité territoire
merci
madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
mais chers collègues le budget accordé à
l'enseignements scolaires affiit cette
année encore une hausse globale de
crédit depuis
6,6%. 0.6 il faut naturellement se
réjouir de cette hausse mais
malheureusement celle-ci ne parvient pas
à masquer la situation extrêmement
difficile dans laquelle se trouvent
l'éducation nationale d'un autre pays
monsieur le ministre vous avez hérité
d'un ministère qui a beaucoup souffert
du passage de votre prédécesseur
celui-ci était enfermé dans des
conceptions archaïques de l'éducation et
éloigné des difficultés de terrain
on aurait attendu une rupture
concernant les enseignants la situation
atteint un seuil critique l'éducation
nationale ne vient parvient plus à
recruter ces 1686 postes non pourvu dans
le premier degré
2070 dans le second degré une explosion
par rapport à l'année précédente
la raison de ce manque d'activité est
principalement financière les
enseignants ont vu leurs salaires chuter
de 15 à 25% à 20 ans nous sommes en
queue de cassement des pays de l'OCDE
monsieur le ministre
ce budget ne prend pas la mesure de cet
effondrement si le président de la
République a annoncé qu'aucun enseignant
de démarrage sa carrière en dessous de
2000 euros net la revalorisation serait
en partie conditionnée à de nouvelles
tâches nous proposerons d'aller beaucoup
plus loin par voie d'amendement
parlons des aesh pour rappel ce sont
plus de 90% des femmes qui effectuent un
travail de première importance auprès
des enfants en situation de handicap
pourtant leur rémunération est indigne
en moyenne 850 euros par mois très
largement en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté qui est aux alentours de 1000
euros comment l'État employeur peut-il
être un tel moteur de souffrance et
fabriqué des travailleurs pauvres
la rémunération est aussi faible en
raison d'une erreur organique
réorganisation calamitose de leur
travail par certains pays à elle le
résultat est prévisible dans de nombreux
académies des enfants handicapés se
retrouvent sans aucun accompagnement à
tel point que certaines écoles acceptent
désormais que les enfants dont les
parents en ont les moyens et recours à
des prestataires privés au sein des
écoles de la République cette rupture
d'égalité inacceptable doit nous alerter
monsieur des ministres il faut tout
revoir leur statut leur rémunération
leur formation leurs conditions de
travail là aussi nous vous proposerons
des amendements vient ensuite la
question de l'enseignement professionnel
les moyens qui sont consacrés augmentent
seulement de 5,3% en 2023 soit moins
qu'une inflation de plus l'enseignement
professionnel souffre d'un manque
chronique de moyens il n'a cessé d'être
tricoté par les réformes successives
moins d'établissements moins d'élèves
moins d'heures d'enseignement moins
d'enseignants en 2023 cette dynamique ne
s'arrêtera pas puisque le gouvernement
prévoit de supprimer 480 postes
supplémentaires dans le second degré
cette année l'enseignement professionnel
a également droit à une double tutelle
puisque son ministère est désormais
également rattaché au ministère du
Travail
ce choix politique traduit une volonté
de répondre aux besoins immédiats des
entreprises une volonté de soumission
des parcours des élèves au marché du
travail or l'éducation nationale et à ce
que je sache l'ancienne l'enseignement
professionnel on fait toujours partie ce
n'est pas la soumission mais au
contraire l'émancipation
l'éducation nationale et la peau donnée
à ses élèves des moyens de s'épanouir
d'apprendre de prendre en main leur
avenir dans la voie de ceux qu'ils ont
eux-mêmes choisis là encore notre vision
est antinomique de la vote mais c'est le
ministre
concernant l'enseignement technique
agricole ce budget met enfin un terme à
trois années successives de baisse des
effectifs d'enseignants mais cela ne
suffit pas il faut rebâtir recruter
revaloriser donner de nouveaux moyens
nous installons seulement 13000 nouveaux
agriculteurs par an dans notre pays
c'est trop peu à la fois pour répondre
aux agents aux enjeux de l'alimentation
mais aussi de la transition nous ne
souhaitons pas laisser l'enseignement
agricole aux mains du privé comme le
campus hectare de Monsieur Xavier Niel
pour travailler la terre il faut former
et c'est là aussi le rôle de l'Éducation
nationale
en conclusion monsieur le ministre nous
envoie accueilli avec soulagement la fin
des années Blanquer qui ont été
catastrophiques pour l'éducation
nationale
ce premier budget devrait incarner votre
nouvel ambition votre nouvelle élan pour
votre ministère mais le quand il n'y est
pas manifestement pas
notre premier avis est plus que mitigé
mais nous réservons à notre vote aux
sorties sera réservé à nos amendements
en séance je vous remercie la parole est
à Madame Samantha casbone pour le groupe
RDPI
madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres chers collègues pendant deux
ans la crise sanitaire a profondément
bouleversé notre système scolaire et si
la rentrée 2022 a marqué un retour à la
normale c'est grâce à la mobilisation
des services de l'éducation nationale et
aux enseignants dont je veux ici saluer
l'engagement
il en demeure pas moins que le métier
d'enseignant souffre d'un manque
d'attractivité dont nous connaissons
tous ici les symptômes pour densité que
deux la baisse continue du nombre de
candidats au concours et l'augmentation
constante des démissions parmi les
professeurs témoignent de cette perte
d'attractivité
sans aucun doute le manque de
reconnaissance sociale l'isolement ou
les difficultés rencontraient dans la
formation initiale et continue ils sont
pour quelque chose
mais ne nous voilons pas la face la
première cause de cette désinfection
croissante et le niveau de rémunération
des enseignants à ce titre ce budget
2023 en hausse de 3,6 milliards d'euros
par rapport à devine 22 apporte une
réponse lucide au sujet du salaire des
professeurs plus de 2 milliards d'euros
financent des mesures de revalorisation
des enseignants il y a bien sûr
l'augmentation de 3,5% de la valeur du
point d'indice de la fonction publique
qui s'applique à plus d'un million de
fonctionnaires sur le périmètre de la
mission que nous examinons ce soir
il y a surtout la revalorisation des
salaires à hauteur de 10% en moyenne
pour créer un choc d'attractivité du
métier d'enseignant
vous le savez dans sa lettre adressée à
tous les enseignants le 16 décembre
2022 le président de la République s'est
engagé à ce que qu'aucun professeur
pardon de début de sa carrière en
dessous de 2000 euros net par mois à
partir de la rentrée 2023 cette mesure
mobilisera
635 millions d'euros de crédit pour
couvrir les mois de septembre à décembre
2023 est représentera 1,9 milliards
d'euros en année pleine d 2024 il y a
enfin l'enveloppe additionnelle de 300
millions d'euros prévus dans ce PLF 2023
afin d'apporter une rémunération
complémentaire aux professeur souhaitant
prendre en charge des missions
supplémentaires
par ailleurs nous constatons que malgré
la diminution continue du nombre
d'élèves en raison de la baisse des
naissances en France les effectifs
enseignants sont relativement stables il
en résulte une hausse du taux
d'encadrement des élèves qui n'est pas
un hasard mais bien le fruit d'un choix
politique cette hausse cette hausse
procède
d'une décision du gouvernement de ne pas
répercuter la totalité de cette baisse
démographique sur l'emploi enseignant
une autre priorité de ce budget 2023 qui
demeure constante depuis 2017 et
l'amélioration du climat scolaire c'est
la hausse du nombre d'avesh pour 448
millions d'euros c'est le programme
français de lutte contre le harcèlement
à l'école programme phare qui concerne
depuis la rentrée 2022 la totalité des
écoles élémentaires et des collèges
publics ce sont les 589 millions d'euros
prévu pour financer la politique de
santé scolaire c'est aussi la poursuite
d'action éducatifs complémentaires aux
enseignements à la hauteur de 188
millions d'euros je pense ici au
dispositif devoir fait qui a bénéficié à
800 000 élèves en 2021 2022 ou au
dispositif vacances apprenante initie en
2020 afin de répondre aux besoins liés à
l'épidémie covid pardon 19 j'aimerais
enfin saluer ou non de notre groupe la
hausse de près de
770 pardon 70 millions d'euros des
crédits à l'enseignement technique
agricole si l'enseignement technique
agricole demeure une filière
d'excellence qu'il faut préserver il est
aussi un pilier de notre souveraineté
alimentaire dont la crise sanitaire a
montré la grande importance pour toutes
ces raisons le groupe RDPI votre a sans
réserve les crédits de cette mission
je vous remercie je vais suspendre la
séance elle sera reprise à 21h30 pour la
suite de l'examen de la mission
enseignement scolaire la science est
suspendue
[Musique]